d'abord un conseil ne cherchez pas de
contrebande y dans les pyrénées si vous
ne l'êtes pas vous même nous avons
essayé on devrait en trouver je sais
bien c'est leur lieu de travail eh bien
non les contrebandiers on vous le dira
comme on nous l'a dit c'est à bayonne
quand les trous
au seigneur de la fraude à l'état-major
bref au coeur du sud
pharisiens étrangers baisse nous avons
cru de bonne foi que nous allions
rencontrer des contrebandiers au
rendez-vous qu'on nous donnait à leur
café regardions jouer europe et se fout
nous rassurer plus tôt le basque joueurs
c'était dans nos fiches en écoutant les
histoires de contrebande qu'on trouve
dans tous les manuels et grâce auquel on
nous faisait prendre patience apn
coup-franc spiritueux jour après jour
car les héros n'était pas n'était jamais
parmi les personnes présentes les vrais
les patrons les grossistes on les
attendait il est allé vue difficile de
les rencontrer du nom pourquoi non il ne
faut pas se laisser prendre l'apparence
on nous attendait à quelques heures de
voiture ici sur la nivelle à 10 mètres
de nous sur l'autre rive l'espagne
commencé enfin une vraie frontière et
nous l'espérions de vrais propos sur 7
contre vente qui nous filer sous le nez
comme si nous étions de simples
douaniers le cadre s'y prêter le cadre
c'était la maison de ramuntcho l'actuel
locataire maintenant retraité et
poursuit des recherches linguistiques
dans la pénombre des journaux au terme
cette promenade que nous avions fait
avec lui le long de la frontière nous
sommes étonnés avant tout que de nos
jours avec les moyens dont on dispose en
france et à l'étranger
la contrebande existe encore et bien la
controverse glisse de part son coeur le
même colis n'est pas considéré comme une
contrebande dans son pays et l'autre à
la fois par exemple une certaines
marchandises s'est exporté de france
l'espagne est bien en france non
seulement ce n'est pas de la contrebande
mais c'est une exportation régulière le
plus souvent qui est favorisée tellement
favorisé il ya des taxes
ça fait peur autrefois le contrebandier
essayer de d'échappée toujours à la
douane même en france pour un pas payer
une petite amende pour n'avoir pas de
passavant ou en histoire comme ça tandis
que maintenant le contre manny est
devenu presque réguliers en france qui a
qui a tout intérêt à se présenter à la
douane avec son coriace et avait déclaré
à cause de la détaxe lorsqu'il devient
contrebandiers 1 espagne tout ça parce
que on s'imagine toujours le
contrebandier comme un garçon avec un
sac au dos sur les chemins la nuit dans
la montagne
est ce que il n'ya que ce type là de
contrebandiers
il y en a d'autres oui généralement se
figurer qui n'existe pas ce petit
poulain que le contre barbier est un
homme qui a toujours et de marchandises
il a trouvé comme par enchantement et
prin sur le dos et passent la nuit en
mer
un pays étranger et qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent a fait ce métier mais un
verdict et il ya plusieurs types de
forte demande
il vient l'entrepreneur et il vient le
transport
je n'ai pas ce n'est pas le véritable
professionnel de la condamnant je pense
que c'est plutôt manoeuvre un porte voix
ils essaient de gagner en scène l oms
salaires les douaniers ne connaissions
très bien enfin on sait très bien au
pays basque que la plupart du temps et
les contrebandiers quelquefois pas vous
mais surtout par nécessité
vous savez que le pays basque la dre
paris les propriétés sont très petites
cette famille très nombreuse alors le
nez ou l'homme des garçons restent à
faire vider de ses parents on te sent
montana ministre
quelquefois un autre se fait tuer alors
il reste quelques fois un jeune homme
deux ou trois qui doivent gagner leur
vie
donc la poêle et il arrive tout de même
je pense au porteur et eau et aux
trajets de nuit en montagne
il arrive même qu'on le surprenne ce qui
se passe quand une un détachement de
douaniers une patrouille tombe sur une
caravane
la règle c'est les contrats miniers se
débarrasse de la charge
c'est la règle du cher et s'échappe
yvonne hafid oui s'échappe
il ne sera pas possible avec du jeu et
des contres bien c'est parce que les
douaniers se contente de la charge et ne
s'acharnent par la suite l'école
terminée c'est ça ne vont pas parce que
dans la rue quand quelqu'un vole un
porte-monnaie un portefeuille dans la
rue et qu'ils se mettent à courir
même s'ils abandonnent deux
portefeuilles le porte monnaie on
continue à le courir après tout d'abord
quelqu'un crie au vol à tout le monde et
m
c'est arrêter le voleur ensuite j'ai
assez de monde pour prêter main forte
aux chandelles tandis que dans la
montagne on ne crie pas au contrebandier
parce qu'alors personnes à ne répondre
oui ensuite les contrebandiers sont
trimestre ils peuvent être une charge
jusque là débarrasser de leurs de leurs
chars ils sont deux fois plus est ces
saucissons poursuivi par conséquent les
douaniers qui souvent ne sont plus seuls
puisqu'ils font du service jusqu'à 63
ans le serbe s'est facilement
de toute façon ils sont 1 1 milliard
pour plusieurs années ils ont tout
intérêt à être bien la population c'est
à dire bien sûr chance qu'ils ne peuvent
pas se cacher et tout le monde alors aux
quelque temps ils suivent la la ligne
générale savait iphone le service est
intervenu mais pas d'excès de zèle
intempestif petit avoir contre des par
exemple courant de vengeance en ce sens
on ne va pas depuis où les bars dans
cette entame demain et ils sont souvent
le bon jardinier une nuit pendant dix
ans de service en valras adresser tous
leurs chouchous leur piment et prague il
recommence le lendemain elle aura au
moment où il a récolté ses haricots
verts par exemple guy faucher êtres
comme ça alors ils comprennent très bien
il ne doit pas faire un excès de sel
c'est à dire le service où il s'est
entendu et pu rentrer dans la dizaine
cheseaux au fond les contrebandiers et
douaniers passent des années ensemble
même village est souvent le même petit
village musée de quelques dizaines
d'habitants quels sont les rapports
[Musique]
seulement en ce sens que le rejoigne
intéressant de refus souvent possible
notre matériel est le contrebas liés à
ceux laissés pendant le moins possible
parce que il faut que ces bénéfices eux
soient supérieures aux amendes le placer
sa matière un métier vrai une convention
à comprendre que tous ou presque étaient
capables de le faire
qu un contrebandier peut se cacher sous
n'importe quel blues n'importe quel
verrez
comme ils se cachent pour s'amuser
devant la caméra il faut de l'ironie le
sens du jeu et du pari est celui du
risque qui est encore le feu chez eux ce
sont des qualités innées une
personnalité d'aspa rennes que nous ne
nommerons pas mais avec qui nous étions
dans les rues ce mardi là a ajouté ceci
au bréviaire départ ces contrebandiers
ils doivent juger le marché être capable
de calcul financier à long terme
avoir le sens commercial la psychologie
des rapports humains
enfin c'est une élite les basques n'ont
jamais considéré la contrebande comme un
péché il ne viendrait jamais à l'idée
d'un vaste aller se confesser son curé
pour lui dit il a fait de la contrebande
quelle heure il est bien allé courir et
go et maintenant le conflit complaisant
sur cette question
[Musique]